al final Habrá segunda vuelta será el 30
de octubre entre el presidente bolsonaro
y su opositor Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
que tiene 5 puntos de ventaja según los
resultados de la primera vuelta sin
embargo bolsonaro ha salido bastante
reforzado de esta primera vuelta por
varias razones los sondeos le daban un
36% de intención de Voto y él ha
conseguido el 43% además ha conseguido
es que se eligiesen varios aliados tanto
en el senado ex ministros de peso de su
gabinete como también en los estados
federados que tenían que elegir a sus
gobernadores concretamente en Río de
Janeiro Claudio Castro ha salido elegido
en la primera vuelta así como cema en el
estado populoso de minas gerais y en San
Pablo el colegio con más electores 34
millones tarcisio exministro de
infraestructuras ha salido muy bien
parado llegar a la segunda vuelta contra
hadad que es representante del partido
de los trabajadores tiene todas las
pintas de poder ganar nos esperan cuatro
semanas de campaña muy intensa y lo que
esperan los electores y el país es que
sean pacíficas Ya que en la primera
vuelta ha habido muchos casos de
agresiones e incluso tres izquierdistas
muertos a manos de personalistas